I'm gonna jump right in Jon Krakauer
obviously wrote a book about this
expedition called into thin air Beck
weathers wrote his own book left for
dead and you also were able to meet with
rob hall's family there's so many
different accounts of what actually
happened on the mountain on this
expedition first one this project come
to my attention upon 2011 I started
reading every book and they're actually
around 10 and way more and endless
articles and and most of them from
people who were actually on the mountain
but they all tell a very different story
because first of all being on the
mountain doesn't mean that you are a
paying attention to whatever was going
on and you have your own perspective on
it and then I found out a lot of the
time people are the head is so damaged
you know basically they are mixing Evans
up and jon krakauer actually and he had
to rewrite his book because he made a
mistake up I thought he had talked to
andy Harris when he passed him but he
found out and they looked for him all
over the mountain but they found out
actually later that he had never passed
it was a different person he was talking
to so you can imagine how confused
people are at that point this made you
know very challenging adaptation because
I really you know I didn't want
necessary i make a first-hand account of
so many of the of the mountain i wanted
to tell the story of a group you know an
assemble film and and but I we travelled
you know we I went to meet Beck weathers
here in LA he lives in Texas it was
incredible you know meeting the man and
and then we went to New Zealand and we
met there john arnold played by keira
knightley we met Emily what Emma
Watson's character Helen Wilton Sarah
the daughter and guy Carter who sam
worthington place and i'm carol the team
doctor played by elizabeth ii becky and
we will ensure that they were going to
do this for us but they actually decided
to let us listen to tapes that we
recorded on the day the phone calls the
satellite phone only the phone call the
whole day so this chapter everything
they cause everything every I all the
radioactivity to base camp and then the
phone calls that follow and this was not
done because people
it was going to be something going on
they do is I'm sure to you know to
improve the communication skills and you
know their misunderstandings how can
improve that what they're doing they
hadn't listened to this for 18 years you
know they'll put it away is a tragedy
and they put it away I mean you can
march and listen to this with these
women you know and guy caught her you
know the strategy of their lives and it
was very emotional incredibly emotional
but it was also very informational
because now certainly we had access that
no one had had before of every detail of
what Rob says on the radio on some of
the others too and that gave me kind of
you know I touched the truth a little
bit you know and it cleared up a lot of
lot of questions that I had but from
there I really what I want it was to get
that truth into the script and not let
you know in all the respect you know but
Hollywood conventions to blockbuster
movies dictate what the truth was you
know I create a villain and a hero you
know which didn't exist that day I mean
the mountain is the villain or storm is
the villain you know and they're all you
know there is hubris there is eco all
these elements come into play I and I
was very clear with John that I didn't
want to sanitize those people I didn't
want to make a [ __ ] obituary but I was
going to humanize them I was kidding I'm
just trying to understand why does Rob
make this incredible mistake to let dog
go up you know and I believe it's
because of compassion you know because
because it been so close before
contained away for him you know and
there is that's the only reason to
understand this action from such an
experienced guide so you have in your
mind what you think is a story that gets
to the truth of what you want to tell us
a screenplay now you have to make that a
visual story and I suspect one of the
first conversations you have with your
studio and working title is let's film
on Everest and the first answer is
probably what about the universal
backlot so in terms of wanting to be on
your show yeah I was guessing but maybe
in terms of actually getting on the
mountain and getting two locations
that represented Everest what did you in
Salvador talk about about what you
needed and what were you able to get
well so go ahead but bob was always very
clear it's like I want this to feel
really incredibly real I want you the
audience to feel like you're there on
the mountain and we needed to go to the
mountain see what it was like on the
mountain and find another mountain to
shoot on to make you feel like you're
there and that's what we did and he did
not let let that go one second one day
and he was always the first one up the
mountain I but here's I mean for me it's
like acting is reacting okay and when
you make a film about man versus nature
part of is reacting to nature you know
and and I was incredibly important to me
to get that I mean I would have got
taken them up Everest but there was no
insurance company was gonna let me do
that right and I have said it I might
sound it might sound a you know like
like you know I'm not a good person but
but I don't mind a little bit of pain
for the actors as long as it's not
injury because i think you know i don't
necessarily think a happy after is an
interesting after you know but that
paint that pain that pain is a pain that
we all went through we were there with
them and we did go up Everest and we
brought the actors up what 17,000 feet
right yeah I basically we from the from
the airport you see the local airport
luckily airport which is the most
dangerous airport in the world on record
we actually there was a helicopter
crashed while we were taking off and
coming back one day and and from there
we have to track you know there was no
there were no vehicles allowed we
basically from there on all we got was
yaks and donkeys you know on our own
backs and we open up the star wagons for
the actors that income they were the
style workers were unheeded launches and
electric blankets to eat yourself in the
night that's what was the yeah and it's
great because it's fantastic because it
was like back to film school you know
here you have jaws
all in on this guy's you know carrying
their own like there's no assistance and
you know and you know they were it was
he got them you know they some of them
was breaking down i want to say i want
to get out of here you know this is not
the life i signed up for but then they
pulled through and and you know became
like a team going up a mountain you know
and and i thought i love that you know
and you actually cares real Sherpas too
I mean so they are on the mountain
surrounded by people who have some at it
is that right yeah I mean the guy who
plays Lobsang you know they got fishes a
kind of assistance Europa he has been
three times on the top of Everest he's
never played in a movie but but but he's
been three times on the top of Everest
and I love this picture we had like we
had a you know one of the studio because
some of the stuff couldn't do it we had
to do in studio and you hang out like a
real Sherpa I've been three times on the
top of Everest sitting on a fake top of
Everest reading a script about the
journey that I actually almost
participated and I go that's absurd you
know